[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN SILBERMAN: Imagine
you're in a traumatic accident
and end up in the hospital.
One of the first things an
emergency room doctor may do
is take an ultrasound
device and use
it to inspect your heart,
your lungs, your kidney.
Ultrasound has become
an indispensable window
into the human
body for clinicians
across areas of medicine.
As powerful as
ultrasound is, access
to ultrasound is still
limited by a very high price,
form factor--
it's usually a large cart-based
system they have to push
around--
and then, finally, years
of education and training
required to use it effectively.
As a consequence,
2/3 of the world
has no access to medical
imaging of any kind,
5,000 children die every day
from pediatric pneumonia,
and over 800 women
die every single day
from totally preventable
complications relating
to maternal health.
We need to do better.
To address this,
Butterfly has developed
a handheld,
pocket-sized ultrasound
device that connects
right to your smartphone.
At $2,000, a
hundredth of the price
of a conventional
ultrasound system,
the Butterfly iQ is a
personal ultrasound device,
a true visual stethoscope.
Butterfly's ambition is
to democratize ultrasound.
The price and size of the device
have solved the cost and form
factor problems.
But to truly make ultrasound
universally accessible,
we need to solve two
additional problems.
The first is guidance--
where exactly to place
the ultrasound probe.
That's typically performed
by a stenographer.
And then, interpretation--
understanding
the content of the
image is typically
performed by a radiologist.
Now, in order to solve
the access problem,
we can't just
scale up education.
It doesn't scale fast enough.
We need to use machine learning.
What you're about to see is
our machine learning solution
to guidance called,
acquisition assistance.
After indicating in the app
what the user wants to image,
the app shows the
user a split screen.
On the bottom, what you're going
to see is the ultrasound image.
And on the top is an
augmented reality interface
that shows the user
turn-by-turn visual directions
that indicates how exactly
to move the ultrasound
device in order to acquire
a diagnostic image.
After acquiring a diagnostic
image, we need to interpret it.
One interpretation model
that we've developed
is for ejection fraction,
an essential measurement
of cardiac health.
Ejection fraction captures
the ratio of blood volume
entering and exiting the
left ventricle each time
your heart beats.
This is currently measured
by clinicians by hand
tracing the edges of
the left ventricle,
and then evaluating
that change over time.
Unfortunately, there's
great disagreement,
even among expert
clinicians, with regard
to exactly where to place those
tracings or even about which
frames that are of
sufficient quality
for reliable evaluation.
This chart shows a handful
of frames and the responses
we obtained from six different
expert stenographers regarding
whether a frame has
sufficient quality.
This kind of disagreement
introduces a real problem.
How do you train and,
more importantly,
evaluate a model when
you don't have access
to a single unambiguous
ground truth.
In our approach to
evaluation, rather
than comparing to a
single ground truth,
we seek statistical
indistinguishability.
Intuitively, this
means that if I
were to show you a bunch
of different estimates,
some from a machine
and some from humans,
you wouldn't be able
to tell the difference.
So, for example, on the
left, what you're seeing
is our model in red,
which is distinguishable.
It has a very clear upward bias.
Whereas on the right, if I
were to remove the colors,
you wouldn't be
able to tell which
estimates come from
the algorithm and which
from the clinician.
So how do we actually
train a model?
We use a conventional
encoder-decoder architecture.
For each frame, we predict
whether the frame quality
is sufficiently clear
for reliable assessment
and also produce a
per-pixel segmentation
of the cardiac chambers.
Now that each frame in the
video has been segmented,
we select a single heart cycle
that is of the highest quality.
Finally, we estimate
the ejection fraction
using the largest and smallest
areas produced by our model
in that heart cycle.
Quantitatively, our
model is statistically
indistinguishable
from human experts.
More specifically,
it produces estimates
that are closer to the average
over all the clinicians
than any of the individual
experts are to that average.
Underlying all this
infrastructure is TensorFlow.
Everything that we do runs
in real time on the device.
This needs to work
whether you're
in a subbasement of a hospital
or in a remote jungle.
We train everything with
TensorFlow and compile
TensorFlow right
into the app using
a bunch of custom operations.
Finally, we also used TF
Serving to improve our labeling
and monitoring pipelines.
To summarize, Butterfly has
developed a handheld ultrasound
device that has put
a high-end ultrasound
cart, a stenographer, and a
radiologist into your pocket.
This is already being
used by expert clinicians.
And by solving the
access problem,
our use of real-time
machine learning
is making the
democratization of ultrasound
a reality around the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
a